in Mexico the government's policy has
been softer than in some other countries
in Latin America for example El Salvador
which really cracked down quite heavily
and quite faster to try and control the
spread of piranha virus there's a sort
of voluntary quarantine here in the
capital in Mexico City other state
governments across the country are
getting a more sort of hardline in in
imposing that quarantine but what we
have seen in the last weekend is more
people going out in the streets that's
according to mobile data perhaps because
it hasn't hit this country and quite the
same way as in other countries like
Brazil or in Ecuador to another country
in South America in which wire kill its
largest city has really been hit hard
there's a little over 8,000 confirmed
cases at the moment in Mexico but people
might be acting a little bit too soon
because the government itself has said
that the peak is yet to come and that
they expect that to come in May they
expect a lot more infections possibly a
lot more deaths in the country and
something that might really influence in
that is a really kill ease heal in terms
of the health problems that a lot of
people in Mexico suffer you can see a
bit more of that in our report now
Mexico's government says that in May it
expects to go into its own red zone with
the cava pandemic with an explosion in
infections and the Health System
stretched to breaking point and it knows
it's heading there with a wait around
its neck that's because 70 percent of
Mexico's population is obese one of the
highest proportions in the world and one
in seven adults have diabetes
scientists say both heighten the risk of
complications or death from covered 19
in Mexico City
Gabrielle says he fears for his son even
as they both tuck into tacos Veronica my
yeah buddy a sec TV daddy I try to get
him to do exercise but unfortunately
right now he can't go but it's very
worrying very worrying for those who are
all wait as we are going for this
outbreak the country consumes moral
through processed food than any other in
Latin
worker and a massive 300,000 people die
every year from illnesses associated
with bad diet to put that into
perspective it's nine times the amount
killed during last year's record levels
of gang fueled violence
now the corona virus and that
slow-burning obesity epidemic are coming
together there's a word for that says
health experts in Mumbai Kara ass
endemic and one that Mexico is
ill-prepared for our particular problem
is that we have less resources and being
a country which is very highly populated
one of the thin highest in the world
without the resources of other countries
and with this join epidemic of obesity
and other chronic illnesses together
week of it it's tougher to resolve
mexico's got far less intensive care
beds per capita than almost every other
major nation in Latin America if the
millions with diabetes and obesity here
get the virus that spells trouble this
isn't something that's just become an
issue now health campaigners have been
trying for years to get the government
to impose tougher regulations on junk
food and they've had some success
attacks on fizzy drinks for example and
just now a new labeling scheme for ultra
processed food but powerful
transnational companies have fought them
every step of the way and with the
coronavirus already here the countries
run out of time to take the tougher
measures which could have helped blunt
its impact John Holman al-jazeera Mexico
City